[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships open phones here at
88255 225 George camel Ramsey personal
host of The George camel show on YouTube
that's camel with a K very popular show
as well as of course the smart money
happy hour co-host with Rachel Cruz he's
my co-host today open phones here at
88255 225 Kathy starts this hour off in
Indianapolis hi Kathy welcome to the
ramsy show hi guys how are you today
better than we deserve what's up in your
world oh I'm trying to get there on your
level um
I um am calling today to ask you guys
kind of what you think my next steps
might be I've gotten myself into quite
the mess um I have followed all of the
rules of never opening a credit card in
my life I'm 27 and I've made it this far
without one and I've kind of gotten to a
point where I am desperate enough that I
am I have been riding the line of
wanting to open one this week because of
all of my debt problems that I'm having
yeah debt problems always solved by more
debt what do you
mean so um I've kind of gotten myself
into a predicament with um bills that
are owed and my shovel is not nearly big
enough and I feel like I'm running
myself into the ground trying to do side
hustles and um I just graduated in June
and started um as a hair stylist and the
money is just not there like I thought
it was going to be and I know you kind
of have to get clientele and build up
your marketing and all that stuff and
after I signed my apartment lease I
found out that I was pregnant so I'm 6
months into that Journey now and I have
bitten off way more than I can chew as
far as what I can
afford okay what does your husband
make um I'm not married oh okay all
right where is the father in the
picture um financially not um he is is
excited about the baby and all that good
stuff but financially not contributing
at
all
um well I I guess I'll just start there
uh he he really doesn't have that option
morally or legally um if you father a
child in the United States of America
you get to pay child support it's how
that works so sorry Bubba you going to
uh you get to step up and uh participate
in the financial side of the the
equation why does he not work or is he
just a
twerp um I would you know it's more I
think I think it's more of a laziness
problem if I'm speaking from my own okay
from my own perspective so you you have
an apartment rent you're not making any
money are you behind on your apartment
rent yes how
far uh at the moment 15 days and they're
wanting to file eviction paperwork today
after 15 days pretty hard
okay is your first time missing a
payment yes it is and that's I think why
I'm in panic mode you mean you've never
been late and after 15 days they're
filing
eviction correct yep and they said that
that's just their policy I guess I don't
really know how to fight that part of it
yeah it may take four months or
something in Indianapolis I don't know
that may be why they go ahead and get
started um I don't know what the law is
there but um
you need to find that out okay because
fear of the unknown is more fearful than
fear of the
known so you need to find out what the
law is in the area how long it's going
to take them to evict you and what the
you know what you can do to make that
right how much is your apartment
rent it is 1,500 a month okay and what
are you making with
hair um just with hair is probably about
1,200 a month and what about the other
what about other side hustles
side hustles included I've been able to
pull about 2500 okay and you didn't pay
your rent what did you pay
instead um I have a car payment that I
pay monthly how much is
it it is 250 is
itrent no it is not she didn't pay yet
either what did you
pay so I have paid um my Wi-Fi bills my
electricity um all of my utilities are
up to date you made 3,700 where did it
go I mean I understand 500 of that maybe
going towards those basic bills oh no no
no the total of all of my income is 2500
a month oh okay so you make 1300 with
the side hustles correct got it but
that's still a big chunk of change that
is
unexplained yes and I think um part of
it is probably the tradeoff with some of
those side hustles so I've been doing um
a lot of with my car so here in the last
30 days is really when it has absolutely
crashed and I think this is kind of just
a rough patch for me because I've been
able to keep up um but here in the last
30 days it's just been kind of a
disaster and I've fallen behind in the
last 30 days okay here here's the thing
um you you have to find a way to make
actual money net of expenses so driving
having your car around with door Dash
and making no net profit on the door
dashing doesn't make sense if that's
what's happening after you pay your car
expenses right like gas okay um so you
might be better off doing something else
but 1300 on side hustles tells me you're
not working
much you know I feel like I am not
really sure how the money turnaround
isn't working out
um I am constantly working as far as
those side hustles go definitely I know
things have slipped as far as um
building my hair business and trying to
get clients in through the door with
that and I've heard that this is a slow
season for that anyway because it's been
back to school but how many hours are
you cutting
here um I would say probably about 30
hours a week yeah and you're working
about another 20 hours a week so you've
got another 20 hours you need to be
working a week that's what I'm talking
about um okay except for the part that
you're 6 months pregnant which makes
this very difficult I do realize that
but we've got to change like you
mentioned the shovel equation then the
second equation we have to change is the
prioritization okay the first thing you
buy is
food the second thing you buy is lights
and
water the third thing you buy is
rent the fourth thing you buy is car
payment
so you make enough right now to I don't
know what you're netting on that side
Hustle but you make enough gross coming
in to have been current with everything
if you had it properly prioritized do
you follow
me yes okay so what we've got to do in
this crisis situation is we have to
figure out where we can come up with
$1,500 the
fastest from all sources and new sources
what we can sell and what you can go do
from there how old are you 27 okay well
Kathy it sounds like you're alone and
pregnant and scared you're putting on a
pretty chipper face but if I were in
your shoes I can imagine the terror I'd
be feeling so here's what we're going to
do I'm going to set up a Ramsay coach to
help you as my gift cuz I've been 27 and
scared and I know how it feels and tell
Bubba if he's going to make a baby he
gets to pay that's how this crap works
this is the Ramsey
[Music]
show if you're like most people your
home is your most valuable asset and
when you want to make improvements it
can feel like everything costs too much
or takes too long but something as
simple as custom window coverings from
blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees every
things backed by their 100% satisfaction
guarantee and shipping is always free
see why blinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings visit blinds.com to save up to
40% off everything sitewide go to
blinds.com for more
information
[Music]
George Campell Ramsey personality is my
co-host
Today George uh Sharon and I I was gonna
say Rachel and I Rachel was a baby but
Sharon and I learned the hard way and
then we later translated it to
counseling Financial counseling cuz we
were working with people that were
struggling when we first started this
place we still work with people that are
struggling around this place uh to go
back to what we called an eighth grade
civics lesson now they don't have Civics
in the e8th grade anymore but they
taught us the difference between needs
and wants necessities and the basic
necessities of life are food shelter
clothing transport portation utilities
these are the basic necessities so if
you find yourself in a pinch where you
can't pay everything that is on the
kitchen table piled up in the form of
bills you take care of the things in
that order food first shelter second cuz
if you've eaten and you have a place to
sleep you live to fight another day if
you're hungry you don't have a place to
sleep you got all kinds of other issues
here that have got nothing to do with
Mastercard or student loans Okay so
food is first shelter second utilities
for third so we're going we got a warm
place to stay uh then we take care of
transportation and by the way probably
don't need to buy any clothing you
probably got enough you're probably like
enough people you got enough for seven
people you know it's you don't even wear
half the stuff in your closet anyway so
you're okay on clothing shut up so you
got the basic necessities we call that
building the four walls of a house
meaning that you take care of the
Necessities first before you do anything
else and then you will seldom get behind
on those key things that
cause Financial stress to become sheer
Terror eviction repossession lights
turned off no food in the refrigerator
turns Financial stress into sheer Terror
but most people if they're able-bodied
and can work can take care of at least
those basic things as long as you've got
income and then the question becomes
well Dave what do I do when I've got all
these debt payments to pay well it's
that's the next step it's going to go to
collections now that's the next step but
but but you're going to be fed and dry
and warm and the collecting the
collections people are aggressive so you
got to tell them listen I got nothing
canot make you hungry though only you
can choose to make you hungry if you're
working and have an income only you can
choose to make you homeless if you're
working and have an income most people
can earn enough to keep those four
things going if the worst of worst jobs
even if you're working horrible you know
$8 an hour or something at and and
working 80 hours of that you can keep
the lights on so to speak the wolf away
from the door but now MasterCard may get
all bent out well so what you know
didn't pay my student loans well welcome
to America nobody pays them apparently
oh my God you know so whatever right so
we're going to we'll get back to those
things I don't want to ignore them
forever but the first step to getting a
sustainable thing is the four walls and
that's that's what our last caller
before the break um needed
uh to hear a month ago yeah it's sad sad
situation you don't want it to get to
that point but a good reminder and
lesson for those out there our question
of the day is sponsored by neighborly
your hub for Home Services when in
disaster like flood or fire strikes
neighborly rainbow restoration offers
homeowners full restoration services
plus mold remediation carpet cleaning
odor removal and more download the
neighborly app to find rainbow
restoration services near you today's
question comes from Joseph in Ohio
buckle up Dave here we go I'm looking
into financing a boat to use like a
house I know and understand your normal
rules for buying a house ideally 20% or
more down less than 25% of take on pay
15E fixed and I know and understand the
normal thoughts on buying a boat as a
toy depreciating asset cash only value
no more than 50% of yearly income when
combined with all other depreciating
assets this guy really knows your stuff
Dave what I'm wondering is how out of
line or not I would be if I combined
those two into a house boat if I
adjusted the formulas and compensated
for the discrepancies properly the
compensating factors I'm thinking about
are buying something used with most of
the depreciation already absorbed and
financing with a higher down payment
over a much shorter timeline the boat
will have some depreciation as opposed
to a house but if I compensate with
extra savings my thoughts are that this
could work out similarly as I know you
would ask I'm currently 100% debt-free
and have a fully funded emergency
fund okay lot to to unpack there
emotionally and financially but Joseph
is saying should I buy a house booat and
can I do it with debt because I'm
treating it like I'm getting a morgage
on a
home Joseph a boat is a trailer that
floats it goes down in value you could
buy a fully depreciated mobile home and
make the same argument but it would
still be a dumb 10-year
plan I love boats son in Ohio that'll be
cold in the
winter really freaking cold living on
the lake woo I can't imagine I like the
lake too but I'm not living on the lake
in the winter not in a boat oh God you
freeze your butt off um and it's going
down in value and here's the thing 10
years from today where do you end up if
you'll if you'll stretch these things P
out past Friday in your analysis the
answers start to become pretty apparent
see when you buy a mobile home you
stretch Str it out 10 years you take a
$70,000 double wide what's it worth in
10 years you know 20 what's it worth 10
years after that zip right and and so if
you buy a car what's it worth in 10
years going down in value you buy a boat
what's it wor well you buy an RV you can
do the same thing I've had people ask
the same question about an RV we always
wanted to retire and travel the world in
an RV that's great pay cash for the
freaking RV it's a toy and don't call it
your house and justify a huge payment on
it because you know what a 2-year-old RV
is to appreciate it heavily hello so I
mean they drop they go down in value so
fast that's what Wago is actually uh
Native American Indian language for
depreciating it's actually what it means
I'm going to have to look that one up I
got to fact check you on that one what
means means down in value that's what it
means in the ancient in the ancient
tribes I didn't know you were well
versed in the tribal languages Dave you
ceased never ceased to
the things I get myself into I'm trying
to figure out how to say that in a way
that I didn't get sued but anyway um
good luck with
that so this would be similar to an
saying I want to live in an RV I'm going
to take out a mortgage onen I don't care
if you get you a boat honey but pay cash
for it and don't try to say it's the
same thing as a house and please don't
try to say it's the same thing as a
house and a car combined you really got
boat fever bad he went to a party on a
house booat last week and now he's
figured out with his calculator how this
is a good idea no it's not honey it it's
going down in value and you're going to
end up in a mess and then you're going
to have to buy a house later on down the
road and you'll be broke well and you'll
have a you know a rusty old I mean you
know an old house boat h e no thank you
i' I almost bought one of those one time
cuz I really had it bad for a house I
could see you guys just having one you
know at the lake to party on yeah but
I've got a house now but but I mean back
then before we had that we were going to
get a house boat and I looked at this
old nasty I mean you can't say mildew
like old houseboat I mean it's old
houseboat mildew is a imagine the main
on level of science you got a boat and
that takes some maintenance let alone a
house regular boats but I mean my God
yeah no no no no Joseph no I wouldn't do
that you don't find any millionaires to
go you know way I made my first million
is I lived on a boat didn't come up
never comes up Robert is in Phoenix hey
Robert welcome to the Ramsey
Show hi Dave hi George um yeah I have a
pretty I guess not unique situation I'm
just in a bit of a bind and I'm kind of
curious um So currently I work in the
technology field um I I bring home about
100 Grand a year um and I'm in I'm in
baby step 2 I've been doing this for
about two years paid off 79,000 of my
original to 2 127,000 Robert you have
done a great job I however have not I
goofed up and brought you on on with not
much time left in this segment I'm going
to make you get straight to the point
it's my fault I apologize okay not a
problem yeah I was looking to um do a
career change but I'm not sure if it's
the right step to do is it going looking
to get it's not initially how quick till
you're done with baby St
2 um by my math another four to four and
a half years oo how far would you go
down an income and how quick would it
come
back um so it'd be going into mental
health I dropped to about 40 Grand a
year you can't do that while you're in
debt and making six figures no you you
can do you can do that later but you got
to get the debt cleaned up and that'll
give you that much more incentive to
work more right now and get the get the
debt cleaned up as fast as possible but
there might be a different way to go
into the mental health field that
doesn't require you work for
40 that doesn't sound like fun this is
the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership based nonprofit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so see if
chm could be right for your family check
out more today at chministries.org
[Music]
budget
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
88255 225 Benjamin is with us in Lancing
Michigan hi Benjamin welcome to the
Ramsey
Show hey guys thank you so much for
having me this is this is great sure
what's
up well Dave I've got a question for you
um how do I cash flow a new construction
um or should I get a
mortgage um well the cash flow is just
you know sixth grade division into the
number of months that you have and the
money you need to throw at it
right okay I mean how much how much is
the house going to cost
so we're we're getting our blueprints in
a little in about a month or so and you
know we're so about a year and a half
ago we bought our Dream property we live
on 40 acres but we also live off grid uh
we don't have any running water we we
use an ouse uh we love it um but we also
have a seven Monon old baby
and we want to get a bigger house going
so all right so you got to put in
Utilities in a house what's what's the
budget on this so budget well I make
$65,000 a year my my wife is a
stay-at-home mom um and we're planning
on doing a fairly straightforward build
uh budget you know I'd be comfortable
spending somewhere around 300,000 okay
all right and how long will it take to
build
it um probably three years okay I'm
planning on doing most the work myself
to be honest with you all right well
that's $100,000 a year $8,000 a month
you don't have that
okay right 300 divided by 36 is
8,000 all right follow me yes that's the
division I was talking about the sixth
grade division and um you know so do you
have any down payment or any other money
we haven't
discussed yeah so so so far we saved
about $40,000 in cash we have a $30,000
of um emergency fund and this is after
15% of retirement towards retirement I
guess okay um so yeah that's those are
kindur the numbers we're working with
okay the property itself we bought for
about 160 uh currently it probably be
closer to to about 200,000 is it paid
for um it is completely yeah thanks to
you okay I didn't pay it you did good
job um so the uh
uh well I mean if you take out a
construction loan we know you've got
$40,000 to put down so if it's a
$300,000 build whatever cash you can
come up with but between now and the
time you're building that you actually
break ground and you start putting on it
let's say you came up with another I
don't know whatever then the rest of it
going to be a construction loan
right okay and then that would transfer
to a mortgage later down the road as as
you finish the house I don't think a
construction loan is going to let you go
three years and screw around with this
and most of them aren't going to allow
you to be the GC they're going to want a
GC signing off on
it okay but uh you can check I mean
maybe you're Local Credit Union will do
that since you got so much equity in the
property they might but um this scares
Bankers cuz people have a tendency in
these situations to not finish and if
they don't finish they've got a really
nice piece of acreage with a half butt
house on it and that's what they
foreclose on it's a mess I've tried to
buy a couple of those at foreclosure
they're a mess and uh but it's someone's
dream that turned into a
nightmare so what I don't like about
your equation is how long it's going to
take
you okay I would do something to tighten
up your time frame gosh I'm still super
against having to pay out monthly
towards a mortgage would if I like
should I would it be better just to save
the full amount of the house like as
tiet like if you can do that you do that
how long do it take you to save 300,000
bucks you got 40 you need 260 more how
long does that
take okay all right if you do it $10,000
a month it's 26 months if you do it in
$5,000 a month it's 50 months 52 months
so we're bumping up on five years at
5,000 bucks a month and you don't make
$5,000 a
month okay so you know you're talking
about 10 years to save up the money at
your current income rate now obviously
you can do something to change
that but it sounds like you have a sense
of urgency here to build something you
know he's got an out house and a baby
yeah that's urgency so I I'm not waiting
10 years I probably am not waiting 3
years I would probably work with a
builder at this point and get it done
faster and take on a reasonable mortgage
that you can knock out quick yeah we
okay I don't borrow money so I would be
doing something completely different
than anything you've done here Brad but
but um but if you're if you take out a
construction loan that converts into a
mortgage that is no more than a fourth
of your uh take-home pay on a 15-year
fixed we don't scream at you about that
so I I think you've got some work to do
yet on adjusting what you can do to
adjust your income up and your time
frames but a long build is hard on the
house because it's it's it it sits in
the weather without a good roof on it
for a while and then once you finally
get it in the dry all the Mechanicals
and the rough end are sitting there and
it's taking it's it's hard on a house to
build it slow it sounds like a lot of
work I mean you sound confident that you
know what you're doing but man an off-
grid build like that sounds like you
better be a pro yeah well I mean it can
it's just hard on the materials sitting
in the weather you know it it's um it's
just you don't want the framing package
sitting there with no roof on it getting
rained on snowed on for four months you
know because you're screwing around in
there doing something else and that's
what happens these he's in Michigan so
that's some rough wins out there you got
you got some weather issues and you know
temperature issues on when you can do
installs on things so that's that's the
thing you got to work through is all
that Brad is with us in Huntsville hey
Brad welcome to the Ramsey
Show hey Dave hey George how you guys
doing great man how can we
help uh yeah so my wife and I eloped
last year in February 2022 and we're
considering having a reception uh next
year late April for about $99,500 we
currently have about 90
$95,000 of debt and credit cards car
debt and a student loan debt and we also
have a mortgage that's currently sitting
at about
$270,000 $1,700 payment per month I make
about $170,000 a year growth 100K after
tax is 401K all that gas and I wanted
your input on the uh on that on that
right
there so you want to throw a $10,000
wedding in April so how much would you
need to save every month from right now
to do
that well we have um some savings we got
about 25k in savings uh but if we wanted
to start saving right
now uh 6 months so 25k remind me again
you got 95 in De
yeah in credit cards student loans and
car debt and we also have a mortgage of
270 and then you make 170 but you're
also having 401K coming out and you have
25k sitting there you're doing all the
steps at once right now yeah you're
doing nothing you're doing nothing we
teach okay all right so what we what we
teach is a process called the baby steps
and um the first step is $11,000
anything above $11,000 saved goes
towards your debt then beans and rice
rice and beans stop all retirement
savings temporarily throw everything at
the debt as fast and hard as you can how
quick do you pay off 70 with no 401K
coming out making 170 and no eating out
and no going on vacations and no whining
really fast like less than a
year 170 minus 70 is 100 you can make it
dude and then you do your way then you
do your
reception after we pay off the debt in
one in less than one year
yeah cuz you guys have already waited
two years to throw this party what's 2
and a half at that point if you guys are
able to do it completely debt
free yeah yeah that's true $7,000 is
$6,000 a month as soon as you're debt
free you have the party the next
month and you celebrate debt freedom and
marriage Tada
yeah yeah so okay the the current amount
that we have in savings you think take
most of that and throw it uh the debt
yeah that's that's ,000 is still D you
make 170 if an emergency hits the next
paycheck covers it well yeah well the
industry that I'm in hey Brad you do
what you want to do dude I'm not arguing
with you we've been doing this a long
time hold on I'll send you a copy of The
Total Money Makeover book it'll outline
what you should do and then you get to
decide what you will do this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with Y
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lumpsum
payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to y refi.com
[Music]
Ramsey thanks for listening America
George Campell Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
88255 225 Doug is in Milwaukee hi Doug
welcome to the Ramsey
Show hi Dave and George it's a pleasure
and honor to speak with both of you you
too what's
up hey um just uh wanting to confirm
what I think you would say but I'm
approaching 6 65 I still want to work
past my 65th birthday I recently became
unemployed U so I'm job seeking um but I
have a small 401K from my last job only
about
25,000 uh and I wondered if it would be
wise to cash that out and pay off
Consumer Debt of about
[Music]
20,000 um well obviously you're not
going to have penalty on it but you will
have taxes on it um what concerns me is
what that leaves us with which is
nothing and you're 65 years
old yeah so
um we OB I mean obviously what you would
love to have is a big old pile of
savings and no debt right correct yeah
and so uh how how can we best get there
and then how do we use this money to do
that um I would prefer to leave it alone
almost as a symbolic act that I'm going
to add a bunch to my retirement as soon
as I can get reemployed and clear this
20,000 mhm but in a worst case scenario
I would clear it I would use the money
and clear the debt but I I think you
need to have the mindset of I got to get
this debt cleared quickly so that I can
quickly add to my retirement Nest T
because you need to be doing both
agreed agreed yeah so what were you
making before you got laid
off I was making about 60,000 okay doing
what uh it support okay all right cool
what kind of debt do you have I do have
uh I have about a
um 15 or between 13 and 15,000 in credit
card debt and another uh 7,000 in a uh
uh no interest loan on some uh machine
room Machinery my wife uses in her
job what does she
make uh she makes about 300 a month okay
$300 yeah $300 yes and what's the
Machinery because it sounds like this is
not going to Roi for
her uh it's uh basically highend sewing
machines yeah she's a seamess by trade
well it's it's there I mean it's not
worth anything now so
um we wouldn't make that investment
again 7,000 to create
300 um 300 is 30 600 a year uh you need
to make a better return on that as a
seamstress or anything else in business
so um but that you're there now cuz that
machines is not worth what you paid for
it so um now it's not because it's used
um yeah I I think you got an opportunity
as somebody that knows something about
it to do a lot of side hustles uh
freelance work as well as pick up some
jobs so I I just you know I want if I'm
in your shoes I want to create as much
income as I can create and knock this
20,000 out as fast as possible living on
a very very tight budget uh I'm going to
also ask her to to put the uh old sewing
machine in gear and let's do a lot more
than 300 a month let's try to get that
to 3,000 a month um and try to get some
income coming in so that we've got a
nest egg to retire on here uh but yeah
you know I do have a side or I did have
a side hustle I am getting somewhere
from now I'm actually uh trying to uh
cash flow training for another uh
another job that I think I'd love more
an IT
shirt uh no what actually I'd like to
become a a Ramsey Financial coach okay
all right um I would not spend money on
that right now if I were you I'd love to
have you as a coach I'm not trying to
insult you I'm just saying I would
rather you go and make some money right
now and get some of these other things
going before you spend money on
something like that I we we'd love to
have you don't misunderstand Doug I'm
not trying to be mean to you but the um
but I also wouldn't be I'd be bit
hypocritical I'm like yeah give me a
bunch of money while you're broke and
you get got you know no I I uh
uh let's call that an encore career once
we clean this yeah let's put that as
something once you've got the you got
the debt cleaned up you got some money
going into retirement and then go find
the money to go get the certification on
that I would do that but uh no I
wouldn't spend the money right now to go
uh in you know effectively into debt cuz
you're instead of paying it on debt
you're going to spend the money on that
so no I I couldn't do that for you I
wouldn't I wouldn't be consistent if I
suggested that even though I do believe
in our coaches and I and I'm again not
trying to be insulting to you Chris is
in Augusta hi Chris welcome to the
Ramsey Show hi thank you for having me
on really appreciate it sure how can we
help I am three
years from retirement um my student
loans I make my1 12 payments I'm in
education for my Public service loan
forgiveness in April so I'll be done
with that um the only debt we have
outside of that is our house and we know
we're going to probably move in the next
five to seven
years um back to kind of where our
people are at um so should I concentrate
on paying off the house or should I
concentrate on building up my retirement
fund what are you investing right now
into retirement
um I've had a 403b in quite a few
different places I just Consolidated
those with a Ramsey specialist um a
fiduciary um it's right at 40 Grand
sorry you broke up with us right at 40
Grand yeah yeah right at 40 Grand uh my
retirement from teaching will be right
at 60,000 a
year um sure are you putting anything
into retirement now at the present
moment no because of the student loans
and we do not have a fully
funded
yet okay then you would not be paying
into retirement or extra on your house
either one you would be did you say you
had four payments left you've been on a
private or are the public student loan
forgiveness for 10
years um you have to make 120 payments
on the student loan forgiveness years
yeah I'll meet I'll meet 120 and April
okay
well I pray that you are one of the few
that that works for you are aware that
only 4% of the people that apply for
that are actually getting it I am yeah
I've been meticulously keeping my
paperwork I'm not and that hasn't
mattered because there are a bunch of
freaking Liars up there I mean I'm
serious when the last time I looked it
was
1.16% of them are approved which is 98%
are not and you know and I promise you
they thought they had their paperwork in
order so um the whole thing is a
freaking sham but I sure hope you get it
okay so what's the balance on the
student
loan uh it's more than doubled since
I've had it it's at 225 right now and
that's because you were holding out for
this public student loan
forgiveness um partially but even when I
was making payments it was one of those
stories where you make your payments and
it still grows and grow the minimum
doesn't touch it yeah because of the
interest absolutely
which makes me want to burn Washington
to the ground um good people like you
having been misled like this I sure hope
they forgive it I'm I'm not hopeful
though uh from a practical standpoint
okay so let's set that aside your first
thing is build your emergency fund is
that your only debt other than your
house yes sir okay your first debt
between now and April build your
emergency fund as build as big as you
can build it okay and then let's see if
the Forgiveness goes through if it
doesn't go through you're going to have
to deal with the student loan if it does
go through that'll be gone and then we
will move to putting 15% of your income
into
retirement okay and uh the rest would go
towards anything else you can find you
go towards paying extra on the house
regardless if you're going to move I
don't care if you're going to move or
not unless you're going to move next
month but uh um because three or four or
five years who who the crap knows when
you're going to do that I mean I don't
know you don't know even just a general
feeling you've got that doesn't change
the idea that you need to get a paid for
house so we need to get for house and a
big old pile of money when we get to
retirement that's the game
plan okay I'm absolutely can do that
yeah say today yeah let let's start on
the emergency fund right now you see
anything else George no that's it but I
mean if that emergency fund it might be
your Saving Grace to start knocking out
these student loans well if it's a Dash
versus a slash they'll reject it that's
how silly these applications have
been and that's not just a Twitter
saying that's an actual syntax I saw an
actual video of that real sad an actual
deal the guys are looking for any excuse
It's just horrible this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show hey George camel here if you love
the show and you want a deeper dive on
your money Journey we've got a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you helpful
articles and tips on following the
Ramsey Way just go to ramsy
solutions.com today to sign up for the
newsletter again that's ramsy
solutions.com to sign up for our Weekly
Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships George camel Ramsey
personality is my co-host today he's
also the co-host of the Ramsey Network
production called smart money happy hour
with Rachel Cruz you don't want to miss
out on anything George is doing
especially on the YouTubes he's uh
pretty good at that stuff open phones at
88255 225 Alex is in Sacramento to start
off this hour hi Alex welcome to the
Ramsey
Show hi thank you for taking my call I
just want to say thank you um because
with your program we were able to
purchase a home and we're now on baby
step four well congratulations well
done thank you so my question is related
to investment and um so my husband and
me were both teachers we both make about
880,000 a year and we don't have any
debt um however we just had a baby and
we'd like to stay home at least one of
us stay home with a baby for two years
so we saved enough money to do so um we
have another daughter so two children
and we haven't started saving for my
other daughter's College
yet um this is my second marriage the
first one was very shortlived I was very
young um however God blessed me with my
new husband and um unfortunately my
daughter's biological father passed away
um so she is receiving social security
income um each month so I'm wondering
should we be investing and should I be
saving money for her to go to
college yes to all of that and uh are
you planning on staying home at this
point have you guys talked through
that yes so right now I'm staying home
with the baby okay and you guys have
crafted a budget and looked at hey can
we make this work in the Sacramento area
off of one income of 880,000
yes we were able to save enough money
great wait wait wait wait wait you said
you have savings you're going to use to
cash flow
this yes how
much uh we saved around 25 so you can't
live on
80 no but we were able to using the
budgeting app we were able to calculate
how much we would need in order for us
to stay one of us to stay
home right which is $1,000 a month for
24 months
right yeah about there yeah I mean you
got 25,000 you said saved and then
you're going to use all that to uh
subsidize the fact you can't make budget
at 80
right yes so you're $1,000 a month over
budget okay and you have an emergency
fund in addition to
that
yes okay so no retirement
okay My worry is you're looking to save
for college do you guys own a home or
are you
renting we own a home okay I don't think
you're going to be able to invest 15%
and save for college and pull off this
plan right now no you're not doing
either you don't have college or
retirement built into your thousand burn
rate
right that's right yeah so that's the
part that really scares me with this I
think we need to hit pause on this or
figure out a different solution maybe
you bring in the extra thousand and we
still need more money than that to
invest for the next two years yeah like
why don't you tutor part-time while
you're staying
home you make 50 bucks an hour in
Sacramento doing
that okay and my daughter the income
that she's receiving from Social
Security is not is that not in your
budget it's not in the budget okay all
right let's stop and park on that for
just a second you're not morally or
legally obligated to do anything with
that money except put it in the budget
because you spend more on your daughter
than that social security check is so
that's just to supplement the raising of
your daughter and your household spends
more money than that than what they give
you on the daughter so it can be a part
of your budget morally and legally and
that's usually what we recommend because
you've got this dialed down so tight if
you want to use that to start a uh a
college fund for her that's fine I don't
care but I don't want you to do that
thinking that this money has to be
marked for that somehow or you're a bad
mom or it has to be ear marked or you've
done something illegal neither one of
those things are
true that was my worry I just want to
use this ethically well ethically would
be if you put it in your budget and you
take care of your daughter which
includes saving for college for your
kids that would be you've done ethical
because you're spending believe me you
spend more raising a kid than that check
each month
agreed yeah easy okay the same thing is
true usually with child support for that
matter it just rolls up into the budget
it doesn't have to be set aside for the
actual child it goes into the budget
because we buy stuff for the child like
shelter and electricity and things like
that in the household budget that is to
for the child's benefit and so it's
ethical moral legal all of the above but
right now you've got the budget dialed
down and you don't have anything to put
in kids college if you want to use this
since it's not including the budget as
long as you're not doing out of some
kind of emotional obligation then I'm
fine with that
okay okay yeah I don't like that you're
burning this money it's not a healthy
place and you're not putting money into
retirement I do like you want to be home
and you're figuring out a way to be home
with the babies I'm all for that okay
but you're really straining at this so
if I'm you guys I'm picking up some
extra work between the two of you with
tutoring is probably your highest income
as a side hustle and try to earn 1,000
bucks a month so that we don't touch
this 20 5 and then that allows us to
start putting money into retirement
possibly okay yeah so let's try to do
try to adjust just a little bit here
you're close I mean th000 bucks a month
on a $80,000 budget it's only 12 a year
so that's not that's side hustle money
that's side hustle money easy side
hustle money so not not not much hustle
just
side and a lot of people Dave don't know
about the spousal Ira for those that are
stay-at-home parents they still have the
ability to fund an IRA which can be a
great thing so don't miss out on that if
that makes sense for you you can do a
full Roth IRA if your spouse works and
you
don't okay so that's called the spousal
Ira so you're just as qualified as if
you were earning an as if you had an
earned income so uh my wife Sharon has
not worked outside the home in 30 plus
years and we've never missed a single
Roth IRA way to go ding ding ding ding
ding ding well the way to do not no
since they started doing IRAs oh I
didn't think about that that was before
my time I guess it it was after we went
broke so there you go but yeah so not
the entire marriage we haven't been
doing it but you once we got some money
and we were funding retirement she we've
always done a spousal to your point
that's a good good reminder Ira because
you qualify for that if your spouse has
an earned income you has to be earned
income has to be in excess of the two
Ira amounts combined but it obviously
would be I mean it's only again 12
14,000 bucks so not a lot of money but
you'll get there you'll get there I love
it I like what you're doing Alex and
that you're planning very
carefully that's what keeps people out
of trouble is very careful planning um
what we're what is a little bit scary is
your burn rate and if we can adjust that
I think you got a fabulous plan this is
the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage AG
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a
$5,000 seller guarantee gives your offer
the best chance of being accepted the
home buyer Edge from Church Hill gives
you an advantage over those other guys
go to Churchill mortgage.com today to
learn
[Music]
more
[Applause]
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today our first ever money and
marriage getaway weekend retreat is this
coming weekend October 19th through the
21st here on the Ramsey campus you and
your spouse will be equipped with tools
to cast vision for your family set goals
create the life you both love the money
and marriage getaway is of course Rachel
Cruz and Dr John deloney the only thing
funnier than that would be if George
camel was involved and then there's lots
of humor so the three of them get
together it's an absolute hoot I can't
wait me and Jay just watch we just watch
the circus when it happens so delone is
the circus I Wrangle the circus yeah I'm
I'm the uh yeah I can't say not my
monkey not my circus on this one my
monkey is my circus baram you put on the
circus that's it I'm the guy so you
collect the
checks yeah I go in the ring and let me
know when that happens all right so
anyway hey the tickets are still a few
available uh I mean literally just a
handful but it is just a couple days
away so if at last minute you want to
impulse come to Nashville and you've got
the money obviously uh don't impulse
something when you're broke That's Makes
You Broker we're not talking about that
but this is a great weekend it is a
3-day event uh October 19th of the 21st
it'll be at our Ramsey event Center here
on campus and the whole team is gearing
up for this we're really excited to have
you guys on campus with us thank you
tickets are $7.99 and again just a few
of them left ramsy solutions.com
events for your tickets Mike and datton
Ohio hey Mike how are
you good Dave and George um I'll get
right to my question I haven't heard
I've been following you for about six
months and we paid off all our credit
cards
and now we're down to nothing but our
mortgage but I have two Parent Plus
loans for my
daughters and they want to do that pay
for play thing for or whatever that's
called that extends them out and I'm 59
and a um almost 59 and a half and I have
a half of I have $500,000 in
401K between me and my wife
life and I also started a new job about
five years ago and I was putting a lot
into that and I have about
125,000 in that and I was wondering if I
should when I get 59 and a half if I
should use that that
125 and pay off in two Parent Plus Loans
how much are they one's
415 and the other one is 88
$1,078 I would just pay them off yeah
okay I was you you are technically
liable they are not I understand that
they said they would pay them back but
but then they said they
W well they're they're going to do that
extended thing well that means they're
never paid back you understand that yes
that's why the extended plan is 30 years
of not even making the principal payment
exactly which
no interest is paid and they don't even
make a principal payment it goes
backwards for 30 years I know the
definition of
stupid yes stupid government program the
DMV visits finance
class I mean that's what this is right
oh God I mean thank you Joe Biden I mean
can't string a sentence together and
came up with this plan oh my God it's
horrible it's absolutely Horrible no no
no no no no you're going to get stuck
with it dude that's what's going to
happen so we might as well own that now
and be done with it did you have an
agreement with the girls before they
went to school that they were going to
pay these yes and they they they' paid
on them but they're they're it's going
they're going nowhere the
41,000 was originally
39 and the 18 was originally
16 so they're going backwards on these
ready from when they took out the Lun
how long ago was that oh gez uh one
daughter is 30 she graduated at 24 and
she's 31 okay so we're coming up on a
coming up on a decade and what we've
done has gone backwards so the the way I
analyze this is that pattern is probably
going to go forward we just discussed
that so how does that work out for Mike
well that sucks is how that works out
for
Mike that's what that's what I was
wondering and but you always say never
take out your 401K but I thought this
might be a good time at I don't take I
don't take it out prior to retirement
after 59 and a half what you're talking
about where there's no penalty and
you've got 500,000 or you got 625,000
we're going to pull 60 something out
plus some taxes to cover these right
well I have my Roth is I have them in a
I have most of it in a
Roth so my Roth would be taxfree I have
about
44,000 in Roth yeah
in the 18 would be I would have about 15
I'd have to take out of a the standard
401 401 because yes yeah you know what
I'm do you sense the cleanliness in your
spirit of what I'm talking
about yes because I just I got my
thousand I paid off all my credit cards
which was
12,000 and now I'm stuck with this is
the only thing on my credit right now is
this and my mortgage obviously I'm not
worried about your credit I'm worried
about about Mike and Mike's daughters
are not paying this that's what they
announced we're going to not pay it
we're going to pay it while not paying
it that's that's what they announced
because they signed up for stupid
governments crap so trusting a
17-year-old's good intentions to pay
back isn't going to cut it and so when
parents sign on the dotted line for
these they don't understand what they're
doing they're potentially decapitating
their retirement when they sign up for
this and it's heartbreaking to hear and
but Mike this is a stupid tax that we
just got to pay as we enter our golden
years and they're starting to look a
little more silver a little more bronze
so what's the um stupid new one called
the save the save plan which is absolute
the opposite let's just stretch it out
yeah it's like the stay in debt plan
they call they nicknamed it save stands
for some acronym
stupid stupid D can't say the stupid
asinine yeah I'm just I'm thinking oh
God so I mean seriously it's a 30-year
plan and when they give you the thing
based on your income it does not charge
you any penalty or interest beyond what
you're doing but it it but it
accumulates principle because you're not
even covering the principle with the
payment and and you know so you have
have to have a doctor fill moment with
these stupid things and go how's that
working for you you know it's not you're
you know you've been you've been
screwing around with a government plan
since you got out of school you're 31
years old it's gone backward $3,000 and
you announced to your dad that the way
you're going to help him out and honor
your word to him is that you going to
pay this is not pay it again and let it
go backwards some more and now sticking
with a higher balance than you started
with exactly oh that's that's the net
that's the net of this now these girls
didn't know that they didn't think that
through but that's what happen was a
manal plan believe in a stupid butt plan
coming out of Washington
DC God Almighty we heard story after
story so aggravating and the bar future
podcast and the documentary of all these
people who were like well the
government's giving me such a gift to
lower my payment based on my income then
they wake up 10 20 years later and their
principal has doubled and now they're
really underwater and they're really
screwed the guy the guy in the other
hour he started with 100 and something
thousand 200 something thousand now it
just balloons counting on the private or
the the public student loan forgiveness
the PS uh which is
not oh it's just you're going to give
David aneurism America costing well I
just hate it for you guys because you're
getting screwed by your own government
the first way they screwed you was they
have put Student Loan program in place
for you to get $150,000 in debt to get a
degree in left-handed puppetry and told
you that was the way to success and now
you're a
barista and you're screwed and it's just
awful it's just awful and then they come
out and go we're going to forgive it oh
no we're not yes we are no we're not no
we yes we are and really they don't
intend to forgive it it's they want to
keep you it's the biggest scam
perpetrated on the American public by
our government mathematically in history
the second largest scam was the genius
that invented the idea that we take your
taxes out of your check before you see
your
check if they posted a tax guy inside
your building and you had to walk out
and hand him cash out of every check
there would be a revolution in America
pitchforks torches because you people
would see how much of the money you earn
you're giving to this government to
misbehave
cave you would see that but no it's just
kind of came out of my check I didn't
notice it yeah but it Tax Collectors
would be as reviled as they were we
would name the guy Matthew after the
biblical as reviled as they were in the
Bible post him inside your building
little Matthews in there collecting the
check him and zakus they're in there
collecting your
[Music]
check
hey folks Dr John deloney here with some
great news you get to choose whatever
you do good or bad moving forward the
choice is yours and when you're
intentional about making good choices
over time they become Healthy Habits
Like choosing to slow down and make time
for a daily practice of prayer and
meditation one thing that has helped me
with the daily practice of meditation
and prayer is hallow Al is the number
one Prayer app in the world and they're
giving you 3 months free to get started
that's 3 months free to prioritize your
mental health and be intentional about
finding peace through calming music
prayers meditation and more and hallow
isn't just Catholic you can tailor the
content towards your faith tradition if
you don't have a faith tradition this is
a great place to learn more about it
from scripture readings and prayers to
journaling hallow makes it easy to
practice mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and choose
peace remember poo is giving you 90 days
free imagine the peaceful habits you can
establish in 90 days go to hall.com
Ramsey today and follow the simple
prompts to start your free 90-day trial
that's hall.com
Ramsey
[Music]
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsy
Solutions on the debt free stage rakesa
is with us hi rakisha how are you hey
Dave hey George so good to be here I'm
great we're honored to have you where do
you live I live in Cleveland Ohio very
cool welcome and how much DB have you
paid off Risha
$253,000 good for you and how long did
that take four years and 1 month good
for you wow and your range of income
during that time went from 60,000 to
375,000 nice job okay what do you do for
a living I am a surgeon oh well there's
that okay we went from residency into
the like the real big stuff yeah I
finished my fellowship training then
became a staff okay how long have you
been finished with your fellowship uh I
finished in uh about two years ago2 okay
so you've been in the big bucks for a
couple years couple years and you didn't
go live like a stupid doctor instead you
went and paid off your bill that's right
that's right look at you I still drive
my 2012 Mitsubishi
Lancer so the lifestyle creep uh did not
get me it didn't creep it did not how
much of this was Med school that over
the 253 uh the Lion Share of it it was
credit cards a time share and then most
of it was Medical School wow about
200,000 a little over whole bunch of
things to get clear way to go so how
long do you remember back in your
childhood how long have you wanted to be
a doctor uh only a senior year of high
school when I uh took a field trip to a
local medical school before that I
wanted to be an engineer okay mhm so
valid dictorian of your class oh no not
at all not know but I did well I was top
10% or something yeah I mean you got in
med school so you're no dummy obviously
yeah well done what kind of surgeon now
I can do dumb stuff with money in
particular so don't put it past me well
we we have all got that ability that's
not the question but I'm just trying to
look at you well done very well done and
we say what kind of surgey I do general
surgery and uh actually weight loss uh
bariatric surgery okay all right very
cool and you're in Cleveland Ohio yes
okay good good doctors in your family uh
no doctors okay yeah all right so you're
the first one uh yes sir I am look at
you wow congratulations thank so what
made you decide to go the opposite of
all of your peers which is keep this
student loan debt around for a decade or
two which is what most of them do and
they go buy a new BMW in a house they
can't afford as soon as they get out of
med school yeah when I graduated in 2019
from my surgical residency I had a month
off before I started my fellowship which
was a two-year at Cleveland Clinic and
um uh during that time I just had some
time to breathe and I was like wh why
don't I get my finances in order so I
started figuring out how I could be dead
free and Wealthy that was one of my
affirmations and so soon after I Googled
that I found the Ramsey program and so
uh man I was hooked when I started uh
listening to the show I loved how you
were kind of you know being hard on
people like kind of that tough love
which is kind of My love language and so
uh from that time I decided to get on
the plan and get after it that's amazing
and so what were these sacrifices that
you made did you just keep living how
you were living or was it hard seeing
how your friends were living at that
point um so yeah it was in a way but you
know I was once I kind of learned about
the plan and had a sense of direction
cuz before that I had kind of no clue
how I was going to kind of get to wealth
and and debt freedom but um I I bought
an efficiency when I moved to Cleveland
uh four years ago I bought a student
that was like 700 a month wow and so I I
definitely sacrificed that way and then
um during my surgery Fellowship I took
on um uh extra call and did some
Moonlighting at smaller hospitals that
needed some coverage what does that pay
uh anywhere from like 400 a day to you
can make probably a th a day so okay
you're you're resident at that point
yeah I was a fellow so not paying you
full dock rate but yeah correct I was in
my fellowship making 60,000 so I could
make a couple uh 1 to 2,000 extra a
month and so I was putting it toward my
debt yeah another okay so but still
mathematically looking at this I'll bet
you you paid the most of this in the
last two years since you got the 375
correct absolutely yeah the line share
once my income yeah uh went up times
five well you already had the habits in
place and now you just added fuel to
this thing absolutely the budget was the
budget was it once I kind of had the
game plan yeah all that extra money any
of your peers cheering you on are they
all think you lost your mind um oh yeah
they were cheering me on they was like
they were like you know that's great for
you my family and friends were cheering
me on I was trying to get most of them
be on the plan but uh uh wasn't as
successful with everybody but had a lot
of support people were like wow good for
you yeah most people in med school catch
a disease called doc itis and when they
graduate they go spend money they don't
have because now they're a big doctor
only they're a broke doctor and so I it
takes them about a decade to recover
from the stupidity two years after
getting their degree or two years after
passing their bars and getting or
passing their boards and getting MD yeah
y so wow congratulations you're sharp
you're a rock star thank you so much
amazing amazing hero I'm scared to see
how much wealth you build oh my gosh
over your lifetime now 375,000 what do
you what's the first you got to do
something big and cool to celebrate what
are you doing I mean you know this
happened what in July I I actually you
know got out of debt officially so I
mean my birthday's tomorrow so this was
my big present to myself to come here
and do my debt free screen but we
appreciate that but you got to do
something bigger uh I mean you got to go
big I mean you make $400,000 a year you
don't have payment in the world right
one of those you ear some kind of cool
celebration upgrade the car something uh
yeah I mean call needs upgrading girl
upgrade that car it runs fine
contentment during this you make
$400,000 a year upgrade that car okay
get you a good car next is a good down
payment on the home there we go okay all
right you do that too you can do that
too you got plenty of money I'm not
saying about a $80,000 car but I mean go
get you a $220,000 car on top of what
you got and yeah at least come on I mean
yeah if you say so I might there I'm
just I'm just telling you we have broke
people that buy $60,000 cars so you you
have earned it yeah you make 40,000
bucks a month I mean or 35,000 bucks a
month I mean come on so hello way to go
amazing way to go I'm so proud of you
you're amazing thank you you're
inspiring hey y'all are inspiring y'all
are such an inspiration to me so I I'm
really thankful for the programing that
I found y'all yeah well we're glad
you're here I hope we can help you in
the rest of this wealth Journey oh yeah
uh we've got the baby steps millionaires
book you're going to be there in 20
minutes for you and the uh Total Money
Makeover book to give away to someone
who's inspired by your story and your
family or friend group and certainly
Financial Peace University as well all
of that's for you just to say thanks for
coming down from Cleveland we are
honored honored honored to meet you
you're a hero thank you you're you you
have complet talk about somebody change
your family tree oh whole everything and
I mean the education piece the whole bit
uh and making serious bank and not a
payment in the world
wow all right count it down
$253,000 paid off in 4 years and 11
months making 60 to
375 count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three two 1 I'm dead
free
yeah that's what I want my surgeon to
sound like woo I love it she's operating
differently now on a whole new level
ohom way you go George she operating on
a whole new level ah this is the Ramsey
Show it's crazy George wait a minute
it's not the Ramsey show yet it will be
in a minute but we got excited we got a
little trigger I got fired up there
that's pretty amazing she's impressive
so here's the trick did you hear what
she said she did I got on a budget when
I had the break I sat down I said this
is where I am I'm going to be wealthy
what do I have to do to get there what
must be true about my life for me to get
there and I'm going to get on a plan and
so she jumped on like every dollar
started doing that uh the every dollar
webinars you and Rachel and uh Jade are
doing those again uh they're free you
can go to everydollar.com bugeting and
sign up it's completely free and learn
how to do what she did and that is take
stock of where you are and end up as
George said operating at a higher level
oh that was just too corny I know but it
was really good I'm a dad now so I make
dad jokes that's good thank you okay but
it's true whether you make 30,000 or 300
cuz people go well raka make so much
money of course uh-uh you saw that
sacrifice when she was making 60 and she
paid off 253,000 too hello big hole but
big shovel most of you don't have that
so there you go that's impressive tell
me it can't be done it can be done this
is the ramsy
[Music]
show
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a 100 if you run a business
with different software systems that
don't talk to each other that's why
there's netw Suite by Oracle in the
early days of Ramsey we were using
different systems for all of our
business units we needed one single
source for accurate data netw Suite was
the software we used to optimize and
take us to the next level netsuite gave
us the visibility into all of our
numbers so that we could communicate
across departments and plan ahead better
and as we grew it scaled with us net
week worked for ramsy and it will make a
difference for your business too join
the more than 34,000 customers who trust
netw Suite to help make them smarter and
make better decisions and level up their
operations to learn more get a free
product tour at netsuite.com
Ramsey that's netsuite.com
[Music]
Ramsey
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
Emma is in Albany New York hi Emma
welcome to the
show hey guys thank you so much for
taking my call sure what's
up so I'll start with a little bit of
background I am 26 years old I have no
debt I have an emergency fund and I just
started saving up for a down payment on
a house good for you in doing this thank
you in in doing this I'm looking at how
much my paycheck is going where and the
one thing I keep coming back to is how
much is enough to retire on now I know
you guys have that General 15% guideline
but since I graduated and started
working I've been contributing between
20 and 25% to my retirement so it's
pretty front loaded and now I worry a
little bit about having too much of my
net worth tied up in funds I won't be
able to access for another 30 plus years
so that leads me to kind of a two-part
question uh first how much is too much
to have in your retirement and how do I
plan for something so far in the future
considering we don't know what inflation
or cost of living is going to look like
by
then great questions and it sounds like
you're way ahead of the curve how much
do you have in retirement
currently currently about a 100,000
amazing and it sounds like you want to
retire early by the way you're talking
you you're saying hey I can't wait 30
years to access these funds are you
saying hey if I want to stop working or
have the option to work at 50 what do I
do yeah if it's possible sure okay it
will be possible in your case what do
you make a
year uh about 95,000 a year good for you
well you're you're doing really good I
would put you in the top 95 percentile
of somebody your age you are kicking it
so this is more of a theoretical
discussion than it is an actual
discussion CU you're you really got it
dialed in let's just say that Emma has
her act together
okay thanks all right
now if you want to do what we would call
some Bridge investing you'll be able to
do that beginning in your late 30s and
still be in Gray shape
so you got 10 years before you have to
worry about
that okay and the only way you'd want to
worry about that is like you said you've
got a lot going into retirement um you
know you're going to be putting 15% of
your income into retirement it's only
$15,000 a year right now and you're
going to put the balance of what you can
find on the house and get the house paid
off after you make the purchase on the
house all of that kind of stuff um and
yeah you know in your 40s you should be
and you should have over million dollar
and so if you want to at that point go
I'm going to start Sid loading some
money over here some of the money I'm
going to save once my house is paid off
I mean you could continue to put 15% on
retirement and have another 10% going
into non-retirement investing just into
you know just an S&P 500 would be
fine if you wanted to I mean that's what
I did I maxed everything out and then I
just threw money to the side and had you
know more than enough wealth long before
I got uh into my
50s so here's what that equates to Emma
you can go down to 15% investing keep
saving for the house that's going to
help you save up for the house faster
get it paid off then you can increase
your investing I just crunched the
numbers here for Dave she's going to
have $7 million at her current rate if
she just invests 15% and you get a 10%
return she's going to is that including
the 100 that's already in there that
includes the 100 you'll have 7 million
by 60 you'll hit a million by you were
on spot on Day by 40 years old she have
a million bucks in that account I
thought she'd have be about there now
that that sounds right and so what that
means is is that when you get that first
million in retirement if you're in your
third late 30s early 40s then just stop
or slow down and then just chunk
everything else but when the house is
paid for you can go on up to 30% 35%
investing if you want to you'll have
plenty of money because you have a house
payment right and your income is going
to go up through time as far as pred as
far as predicting what returns are 40 or
50 years in the future no one obviously
can do that or what inflation's going to
do 40 or 50 years out no one can do that
um when I was your age it was 40 years
ago and I started talking about doing
this stuff and now I got a bunch of
money in mutual funds that's the
equation it's not some nerded out tenth
of a point to two ten0 of a point to I
got to figure out the 12 B1 fees or I
got just invest invest invest invest
invest in good mutual funds that have a
long trck record they're going to keep
you ahead of inflation especially inside
of a retirement account uh because the
companies that cause inflation are the
companies that you're buying stock
in by definition that's a hedge okay so
if you're buying stock in computers the
value of Co the cost of computers goes
up that's inflation if you're buying a
stock in uh oil and gas you know in your
mutual fund and the cost of gasoline
goes up which it has over 40 years then
guess what it's built into your the qu
the profitability of your company you're
buying into so
you know ultimately the stock market in
in itself is basically an inflation
hedge you're because you're the way you
hedge against inflation is you buy items
that are
inflating houses and companies that are
going that are that are charging
inflated prices due to inflation that's
the name and that that's what you're
doing so uh that the way you're going to
build wealth you don't have to spend a
lot of time fretting over uh you know
the the economy or inflation or
something else the economy goes down
woohoo we're buying stock cheap economy
goes up woohoo the value of my stock all
went up you know yeah and based on the
Way Emma's talking I think she needs to
have some balance live her life you
don't need to funnel every single dollar
into investing right I want you to enjoy
some of it too and right now you're very
much on track to have plenty of money so
I'm not that worried about it done a
great job crushing it Franco in Las
Vegas hi Franco how are you hey Dave hey
George uh very excited to be talking to
you today sure what's up
uh so my question for for today it's um
should I buy out my ex-wife out of the
house or should I keep waiting for the
house to sell considering the slow
months
ahead um so to give a little background
on that um I recently went through a
divorce that finished about a month ago
it lasted for about eight
months um and since uh since the
beginning of the relationship and even
beginning of the divorce I've been
paying for the mortgage for all the
bills related to the house and for all
the debts that she's carrying uh right
now plus the three dogs that we used to
have together um you're paying three
dogs that you used to
have I'm so
confused why would you be paying for
dogs that you don't have for an
ex-wife because uh since the beginning
of the relationship she basically
decided not to work even if I encourage
her I even pay
her have you got the
dogs no I don't then they're no longer
your
responsibility okay if you want to take
care of the dogs go get them but
otherwise quit paying for the freaking
dogs for your
exwife come on man now and so she's in
the house she's in the house yes and
you're paying all and what did the
divorce decree say about the house it
had to be sold uh yes it's in the
process of being sold uh it's been three
months in the market with a lot of
showings but it hasn't been sold yet
okay and and you're paying the payment
yes I'm making the payment and I'm
paying uh the bills related to the house
as well okay and she's living in the
house yes what a wonderful
deal I bet I bet it's hard to show that
house and when you do it's
messy uh I I'm actually not allowed to
enter the house she prefers uh for me
not to so what makes you think you can
buy her
out um so I've been uh thinking that uh
I could buy the portion that it will be
the same uh for her if the house gets
sold is she going to move with the dogs
then yes you sure if I do so I mean I I
would hope so so far you've not done
very good
deals yeah she's got to move you
understand that
yeah I do and the dogs at what point do
you stop paying all of her bills when
the house sells yeah are we sure about
that uh yes it's part of the divorce
decree yeah but is Franco gonna
quit oh yeah yeah yeah I'm going to quit
I I've how much does it take to buy her
out uh about
50,000 okay but it's not worth that
because after after expenses you're not
going to net 50 on half you're not
netting a full 100 when it sells are
you uh so the price of the house is
about uh on the market 630 right now and
because we still owe uh a big amount on
the
house uh we owe uh about
450 okay there's not yeah that's about
right then okay if you can come up with
50,000 and you want to buy her out and
sell the house yourself later but she's
got to leave and I don't think she's
going to this is the Ramsey Show Dave
here you can find all of our shows with
the Ramsey Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsey Network app in your
favorite app store
[Music]
today
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships George camel Ramsey
personality is my co-host today he is
the also the co-host of smart money
happy hour Rachel Cruz on the ramsy
networks and the George camel YouTube
Show camel with a K be sure you check it
out don't miss miss him it's pretty
informative stuff phone number here to
talk about your life and your money is
88255 225 Christina is in Austin Texas
hi Christina how are
you doing good how are you Dave better
than we deserve what's up that's good
thanks for taking our call um so a
little bit of background on us my
husband and I uh we 26 and 28 years old
and um I have um Met Life settlement
that I've been receiving since I've been
21 um and my husband has disability with
the VA and so outside of our jobs um
we're bringing an income um so alog
together really in a year we probably
bring in about
990,000 um but lately we have been
having a lot of debt um from student
loans to credit cards to car payments um
and I feel like the money that we're
getting to utilize for other things is
just going right to debt um and so we've
been talking around the idea of possibly
selling our home
um and paying off our debt with the
equity we've built up over these last
two years um but my husband he do think
it's a good idea he's scared to do that
um and so I don't know we've just been
talking around the idea and we just
wanted to get your input on that because
um this my life settlement I won't have
it forever um and so I would love to
invest that into other things instead of
jet um but I wanted to hear from you
what your thoughts
were
well you're not quite ready to invest we
got to clean up this mess and selling a
home is a big deal and it's generally
kind of a last ditch thing if we have to
to get out of this but I'm not sure you
guys are there yet making 90k how much
Consumer Debt do you
have uh so we have about 110 maybe 105
um how much of that is
cars um about
60,000 um that's a lot
car it is um and I've actually been
telling my husband for him to get rid of
this truck um I'd rather you get rid of
the truck before the
house yeah and but he doesn't think that
we'll get back enough to pay off the
truck um and so but I I think he should
give it a try to see what how much we'll
get from it but he just doesn't we've
been getting um what's that word we've
been getting uh offers of like 24,000
and we owe about 45 on it still um I
wouldn't look at offers I mean you sell
a private party and you're going to get
way more than offers from
dealerships okay um yeah and so we we
have too many on vehicles um and then
school loans is another
40,000 um and then credit cards is
probably about 5 to
7,000 you you make enough to get out of
student loan debt and get out of the
credit card debt if you didn't have the
car payments but your car Cho your car
choices are what have sunk you not your
house okay so the truck we get rid the
cars s the truck okay what are the
payments on those
cars so our so I have uh my car is are
$376 um and then his truck is about 740
762 goodness gracious every month so
you'd free up 1,00 bucks just by getting
rid of these cars wouldn't that change
your
life yes it would um could you pay off
some debt with an extra 1,00
bucks yeah we could um and right now
we've been throwing a th000 to debt
every month but um it just gets me angry
every month to that we're throwing it to
debt you know um and I know yeah you
asked about selling the home George is
right not before we sell both cars and
we work a hard plan with driving a
couple of hoopties working extra
jobs okay what's the nature of the Met
Life settlement what's that from um so
it's from a car accident that I had um
with my family when I was younger I was
about four years old my brother died
from it um and so my parents were
gracious enough to separate some money
for us once we hit
21 um and so at 21 we received 50,000
which I paid another portion of student
loans at the time because I had gone to
a private
institution um and so that went to
student debt but then I still had the
40,000 pending
um when does what I'm sorry when does
the 40
come uh the 40 like the school loans
that's what I right now $40,000 worth of
student loans pending I'm sorry the is
the rest of the money coming from
MetLife a monthly money or a lump sum uh
yes yes uh no monthly money we're get
I'm getting 2,429 for it every month um
for
long uh when I turned 35 so I have about
uh nine years to go okay all right yeah
you guys need to get I I the the truck
is glaringly absurd in your in your
numbers it's the thing that sticks out
and screams
stupid okay and yeah it's got to go it's
out of control and U probably your car
too but at least the truck because
you're making 90k driving a $60,000
truck that does not make
sense um nice truck
though uh yeah he's not going to like to
hear that D he's got get yeah well he's
going to guess what he's not homeless
he's just truckless it's a better choice
fact that he'd rather sell his house
before his truck tells me that truck is
an ego
play yes okay all right well yeah good
luck with that I hope you talk him into
it cuz that's what you guys need to do
the best the best thing that you can do
you've got to clear this up and
so goodness gracious yeah I remember
yeah the if your truck payment's bigger
than your house payment you might be a
redneck yeah it could be it's
possible Rachel's in Canada hi Rachel
welcome to the Ramsey
Show hi hey what's
up so my husband and I have an
opportunity to look at taking a
greenhouse business over however I don't
have a single idea of what questions to
ask when we go in to talk with them why
would they let you take it over if
they're making a profit why would they
not sell it to
you he is Keen on um remaining in the
business for a little bit longer he's
the sort of fellow that's going to work
until his dying day the owner um there
yes okay how are you taking it over if
he's still working there till his dying
day uh he wants to train somebody up
into his position somebody that's
passionate about it but has a vision to
take it in new directions and uh for a
couple like how him and his wife were
when they first started it and when will
the ownership be transferred to
you these are all questions that I have
for them we have talked on and off
throughout the on season and so so it's
been very very short conversations and
now I want to actually sit down talk
with them what do they expect what I
want to know does it make a profit cuz I
got a feeling it
doesn't I want someone who's passionate
about it and willing to work for no
money cuz this is not really a business
it's a
hobby Fair um he's been doing this for
22 years he's well established in our
area and now he's just getting old and
doesn't want to do the really long days
anymore or anything like that so it does
make a profit I yeah I want to know how
much and I want to know what the
business bus structure looks like I mean
you got to get in there and learn all
the business aspects of it and determine
if you want to take it over um sounds
unusual and when something sounds
unusual there's a reason it's unusual
this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
George camel Ramsey personalities my
co-host today Abigail is with us in
Charleston South Carolina hi Abigail how
are
you I'm all right how are you better
than we deserve what's
up um well it's a bit of a financial
question as well as a relational
question um I uh my husband and I got uh
married three years ago we've been
renting for quite a bit and then um uh
we went up near family and they uh they
offered to sell us a house well my
mother-in-law is very controlling which
is the relational part of the question
um
she she
controls everything and has the
codependency issues where she will go
and she will buy something for you even
though you were going to buy yourself
and you didn't want her to buy it or for
instance the house that they were trying
to sell us so she bought it now we're
working on it which
is let me stop a minute did you guys buy
this house or not we were going to okay
so You' not you've not bought the
house no we haven't okay she has okay so
you're not getting that house what are
you going to
do well right now we're working on it
and why are you working on her
house um because we're supposed to be
buying it from her so you agreed to buy
it
later yeah is this in writing or is this
just a hand handshake
agreement it's a handshake agreement
really okay when you buy it from her
what does that look like you proba you
go get a mortgage and you purchase the
house and then you're the owner
right yeah and from what I was like what
I was wanting to do was I was trying to
get my husband to agree to get a a
mortgage and then some on top of that to
do repairs well we need a contractor for
that and my husband's bucking and
kicking to to not get a contractor
because he's supposed to get his
contractor's license soon and he doesn't
want to put his further in debt what
does what does that have to do with your
mother-in-law I don't know how
to approach her um why does she need to
be
approached well cuz we're living with
her right now oh or she's living with us
we're both living with her mother what
um and she has her own home she just
refused to go home
what do you guys
make um my husband started a new job in
June doing HB and right now it's
about uh it's up to 2,000 every two
weeks so 4,000 a
month and and how old are you
guys uh he's 3 and I'm 23 okay we've got
uh two kids okay and you're staying home
with the kids it sounds like the first
order of business to uh create some
reasonable relational boundaries is to
create some physical separation and you
guys need to go you guys need to go get
an apartment
tomorrow that's what I'm I'm I was
thinking yeah but I don't know how to
talk my husband into that well then you
don't have a mother-in-law problem you
have a husband
problem maybe maybe the Mommy's boy
needs to take care of his family instead
of his mommy's wishes
she got three sons she does this to all
of them I'm sorry and she has three sons
and she does this to all of them she
didn't do anything she didn't do
anything to him that they didn't let
happen I don't think she's I don't think
she's the problem I think your husband
is any any boundary you try to set it
immediately devolves into yelling move
out move out tell your husband I'm
leaving I hope you come
too me and the kids are getting an
apartment this is untenable if she
chooses to end the relationship over
this that's on her it's not on
you but this isn't not a relationship
anyways to begin with this is not your
mother-in-law's fault this is your
husband's fault and your fault you
agreed to move in with her and you knew
this before you moved in with
her yeah I thought she'd go home no you
didn't
no you
didn't you knew this you knew exactly
what you were dealing with and you chose
to ignore it trying to make a financial
deal we're trying to save $2 and in the
middle of it we're putting up with the
Wicked Witch of the
West yeah to save
$2 you guys need to go have a life you
and your husband go build a life and you
can love her she's a lot easier to love
from a
distance you got that right yeah she
needs some distance
but she's not the problem you and your
husband are the problem you've you've
you guys just stepped up into a bear
trap and then you're bitching about bear
traps
yeah yeah so play this out you get an
apartment she's mad I I don't even care
about her that's it I mean she's she's
not relevant in the discussion you guys
need to decide we are going to do things
that are smart relationally and smart
for our future and not put ourselves in
untenable toxic situations to save $2
whether it's working on the house
without a contractor's license or buying
a house from this woman who's
controlling why you enter into a deal
why you go along with entering into a
deal with this woman to buy a house from
her is beyond me these are people that
are Best Kept at arms length not right
up close you know this now you're only
23 so I shouldn't fuss at you but you
know you call me and you're all torqued
out about her and I'm telling you you
and your husband can solve
this yeah but she's still mothering him
and he likes
it yeah yeah she pays for just about
everything well quit taking her money
I'm not taking your money anymore and
you're not controlling my life anymore
you don't have to be mean about it but
just be kind and just go listen you know
we've made some mistakes by setting up
our relationship with with you earlier
in our marriage and we're going to have
to change that so here's the thing we're
going to have a little physical
separation a financial separation and a
real estate separation from you so Mom
you need to get that house on the market
and get it sold we're not buying it
we're going to go rent an apartment and
we're going to save up some money and
get us a
house yeah it's completely clean and
she's not going to like it but I'm not
taking a poll here she doesn't get a
vote the problem is you all gave her a
vote
yeah again you don't have to be unkind
you just be very firm and just say it
and if it devolves into yelling that's
on her but I don't put up with people
yelling that's
ridiculous yeah I mean what husband is
going to let his 23y old wife get yelled
at come on
man tell him to run down Walmart and
pick up a backbone they're on aisle
three
Abigail this is not going to be fun and
what's going to happen when you say all
this to him if he watched this call back
what would his response
be would it be they don't understand
like it's not like that she doesn't give
me an allowance it's different is that
what it would be he arguing with the
recording saying well I we we shouldn't
get an apartment cuz we're getting it
from my uncle and what's he going to
think stop taking things from your
family there's strings attached it
doesn't end
well yeah start your own life don't back
out of this deal stop taking allowance
and if you all need to go make more
money then go do that the financial
incest in this is
unbelievable I know yeah I mean really I
don't know what to do you know I mean I
I what you do is you have a marriage
problem you and your husband need to
separate from these people far enough
that they don't have any Apron Strings
or wallet strings controlling you get an
apartment there's apartments in
Charleston South Carolina nice ones go
get you an apartment and go get you go
get a job he go Gets a Job whatever we
got to do to make it on our way we're a
young married couple we don't have any
money we're trying to get started but
you don't have to live under the thumb
of the control of these toxic human
beings it really it needs to stop you
asked hon that's what I'm telling you
but really you can't blame her anymore
after
today if you if you want to blame
somebody get you a mirror it's your
fault after today those are also at
Walmart yeah Ila 4 yeah they're right
over next to the backbone aisle the
mirror aisle yeah and you guys you guys
got to make some decisions here mama
don't get to control you unless you
allow her to you're like grown people
and stuff this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
a
George camel Ramsey personality my
co-host in the lobby of Ramsey Solutions
on the debt free stage amus and Hannah
are with us hey guys how are you we're
good how are you we're blessed welcome
where do you guys live Charlotte North
Carolina awesome welcome to Nashville
and how much debt have you two paid off
94,000 all right how long did this take
18 months good for you and your range of
income during that time whenever we
first started we're making around 97,000
this year we'll file taxes around 180 to
200 whoa what do youall do for a living
so uh I am a nanny and I'm also a house
cleaner I started that business when I
was uh in debt so I was cleaning houses
um got my clients and toil good money
from morning to night good money good
money and yes and I run a video
production company we film weddings
corporate events commercials and my wife
helps me as well wow you guys are
working hard we tried to way to go what
kind of debt was the 94 see we had a car
for uh like 37,000 student loans for
around 52,000 and an iPhone 12 for 599
bucks which we paid off first how long
you guys been
married uh this December will be two
years okay so about the time you get
married you start this stuff tell me
about about it how did you get connected
up to the ramsy deal so it was a couple
months after we got married we gathered
up all our debt and we said this isn't
going to we we got to get this out of
here and we started listing them from
smallest to largest and started B paying
them off as soon as possible yeah we did
because as soon as we got married I was
like man we're making all this great
income we have all this money coming in
but the checking account is staying the
exact same where's it all going it it's
going to a stupid dealership it's going
to stupid federal student loan program
was going to Verizon and it was going to
all these places and I said I work way
too hard to have this little money in my
checking account and just like you say
Dave something had to change my life so
I could actually change something for my
future and have more than a couple
thousand bucks to my name making that
much money a year amen preach it how
long uh how did you guys find us uh one
day I was uh I followed you on years uh
on on Instagram and then you eventually
recommended on YouTube and I was like
man some of these people are uh I can
definitely relate to and I was like man
making all this money not having a lot
of money or having some of these
stresses um I followed you and then a
few months before we got married we cut
up all our cut up all of our credit
cards and we said okay we're done
borrowing money even though once we
started paying off debt we accidentally
fell back into it and then I had to
repent for about the next year because
of that but even throughout that whole
process um yeah we just kept on
following you on social media and
YouTube and love your content we went to
go see you in San Antonio Texas at your
Building Wealth conference we LED FPU a
few years ago and then also purchased
your financial Coach master training to
help coach other young people on how to
become debt free and achieve their goals
wow you guys are on fire fully in this
thing man that's impressive and along
the way you guys doubled your income was
that just because you were Furious about
the debt payoff and then it just kind of
stuck I got so mad at it and I said it
has to go and then uh because for
example within our video production
company we we film weddings then we edit
weddings and whenever we were in debt I
said well I can make more money editing
weddings for other people so I stayed up
late 11: 1200 1:00 a.m. sometimes
editing for other people and then once
we started doing that uh a lot of people
started sharing the word about it and
Dave just like you said in in a small
business if you just show up on time and
you do a great job you won't have any
competition and that's what we started
doing and then we now starting to hire
other contractors to help us throughout
the process and our company grew
actually because of the intensity that
we achieved through baby step 2 so it
just it overall helped our business as
well as payoff debt wow how old are you
two 23 wow U then I was 22 when we made
our last debt payment just turned 23
last week wow congratulations you guys
are heroes you got the whole rest of
your life to live with with
intentionality and with a big old pile
of cash cuz it's not going to payments
yes sir yes sir y'all are amazing very
very well done all right uh Financial
coach what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is ever uh ever
since the beginning we tithe 10% on our
income to our local church and we're
also extremely generous throughout the
throughout the process uh we did tiptoe
into baby step seven sometimes of just
being extremely generous throughout the
process because generosity is so much
fun in my opinion so we kept on tithing
10% we just uh we we sewed seeds with
other organizations and people uh so
we're extremely generous but also I mean
we just we we worked together it it was
you worked we worked all the time all
the time we're generous but we made sure
that we within communication with each
other we didn't go spend money behind
each other's back we're completely on
the same page I mean there were some
nights I was editing on the couch at
11:00 p.m. while she was doing editing
on her laptop as well and we worked all
of the time yeah yeah and now you got no
debt and you're 23 and um besides your
house not yeah not not waiting on
someone else to clean up the mess yeah
no exactly that's extra weird see most
23y olds out there they're going well
it's the wages I they just don't pay
enough these days so I can't get ahead
it's the Boomer fault it's the Boomers
because we bought cheap hous the guy in
the White House and you guys just went
wait we can go make more money we're not
scared of work and now you control your
own destiny in that way I sometimes
scrub toilets with her she was like hey
man just for fun no she said man have a
3,000 ft home I said I guess I need a
pair of gloves as well I'm helping you
as soon as I close the laptop I'm
picking up what's the average amount you
can charge for a house for cleaning 150
that's amazing it takes a few hours oh
yeah she sometimes two or three in the
day and then editing what what can you
get paid to be uh editing other people's
weddings about 500 to $500 $800 and for
a wedding video between 300 to 5,000
what does that hourly come out to uh I
can do a five $500 edit in about three
or 4 hours wow so about $100 an hour
something I can do anytime throughout
the day and just work hard and be
generous yeah so you don't have to just
sit in Doom scroll instead you edit oh
yeah 50 bucks 100 bucks just doing these
side hustles turned into a business yes
sir where money comes from amazing you
got to work yeah God I love your parents
I don't know who they are but I love
your parents they're right here great
job Mom and Dad proof that if you teach
a kid to work you really don't have to
teach him much else so figure it out you
know every parent listening is like I
wish Johnny was more like him yeah
really the uh 23-year-old we were
talking to a while ago with a
mother-in-law issue yeah uh a whole
different 23 year- old's here this a
whole different thing man amazing yeah
well done you two very very well done so
proud of you who was uh who was cheering
you on as you
went these lovely people over here moms
and dads yes they were supporting us um
through it all and we so they think you
were a little crazy though a little bit
crazy y'all are a little crazy in such a
good way all right you guys are still
editing you guys are still cleaning
houses and babysitting you should have
two or three cleanings in a day then
babysit at night and I won't see her all
day so I said I'll either be bored I'll
miss her so I might as well work and
we're just working at the same time and
all of a sudden we just noticed our
spreadsheet uh baby step two just kept
on dropping lower and lower and lower we
said oh my goodness we're out of debt
and we actually have money because we're
not giving it to people anymore boom
just like that you guys are you guys are
fun well done I'm so proud of you young
couple your future is so bright it's
unbelievable fabulously done we've got
the live and give box to give you that's
the baby steps millionaires book you're
going to be there in God 20 minutes
you'll be millionaires before you're 30
the way you're going this is crazy and
Total Money Makeover book as well to
give to somebody that's inspired by you
and you are inspiring and the total and
the Financial Peace University
membership as well so very well done you
guys wow power couple baby I'm impressed
mic drop mayus and Hannah 23 years old
Charlotte North Carolina 94,000 paid off
in 18 months making 97 to 200 what's
their secret work all the time count it
down let's hear a debt free
Scream 3 2 1 we're de
free
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah love
it boom I wish I could just bottle their
energy and sell it that's impressive J
gen Z gen Z Red Bull right there that's
all you need right there talk to amus
and Hannah we're going to call it I may
have just given them their next business
idea and here here's the thing
somebody's going to watch this and say
well I don't really want to work that
well then don't about not having
the results yeah if you want those kind
of you want the results you put in the
time if you want to win the Super Bowl
you got to practice you got to play hard
every down even between the plays you
got to be working I mean it's it's you
know you don't you don't achieve
Excellence without getting it I mean
they got it get up leave the cave kill
something and dragon home man powerful
key very powerful nothing stopping them
yeah unless you're willing to do what
they do don't whine about what they did
and what they got they got out of debt
in a short order soon as they got
married boom just like that this is the
ramsy
[Music]
show
w
[Music]
our scripture the day Isaiah 45:2 I will
go before you and will level the
mountains I will break down Gates of
bronze and cut through bars of iron
Henry Ford said when everything seems to
be going against you remember that the
airplane takes off against the wind not
with
it spoken like a car
guy but it's actually true I just kept
thinking they had it planes back then
that's impressive oh they didn't they
did they did by the time he died yeah
all right Sean is with us in Louisville
Kentucky hi Sean welcome to the Ramsey
Show hi Dave and George thank you for
taking my call sure what's
up um so I my wife and I are looking
into kind of upgrading in home uh we
currently live in 1500 square feet and
we have three kids 7 five and six months
and um with school choice looking at the
location that we would be moving to our
expenses would be staying the same but
we'd be moving from 1,500 square feet to
4500 square fet um the the question I
have is though um and I guess the kind
of concern I have is we yes we'd be
taking on more debt um for a
mortgage um but again with the school
choice it would allow it to be the same
uh expenses so you mean not paying
private
school correct yeah so we'd be still
sending them to private school um but we
wouldn't have to pay that
expense because of the school choice you
mean the school has a has an has a a
voucher program correct yes okay so
you're moving into an area that has a
voucher program you could use that
towards your private it would save you
that
tuition okay um but your house payment
is going to be how
much uh the house payment for we're
going to do a 15-year uh it would be
2500 a month and what's your take-home
pay the take-home uh pay monthly is
9,300 a month after tax all of you know
that's net 401K coming out before that
yes correct I I would do this it fits
every guideline we talk about yeah yeah
is this the I guess the only thing I um
kind of had like a little hesitation
about is like I guess if it
ever uh you know wasn't like that if
they didn't have that policy in place
you know um so moving to a different
County and the county that you're moving
to has a voucher program how long have
they had the voucher
program uh for over 10 years okay uh do
you have anything in the political winds
that makes you think it's going to go
away I don't think that state I wouldn't
think yeah but you
know I I well I mean you can't tell
about anything for sure I'm not saying
but I mean if if there's something in
the front cover of the newspaper right
now then yeah right M yeah but but if
they've gotten a voucher as
controversial as vouchers have been U if
they've gotten it in place and have
stuck with it 10 years they sound like
people that are going to stick with it
to
me yes yeah I I think it's benefited
them greatly yeah it's probably good
it's probably done what it's supposed to
do which has actually benefit everyone
involved so um yes yeah because it well
anyway moving along from the politics
but the uh uh but yeah the the um
financially I would do what you're doing
MH I think I like it yeah if the hey you
know what if the voucher system goes
away in four years you can
move yeah this is a house it's not a
permanent it's not
permanent yeah yeah one kind of security
thing that I had like is if it if it did
go away there's good schools within that
County um that we could fall back onto
if we absolutely had to so I just you
know was well and the other thing is
going happen is during say it's 5 years
from now six years from now your your
income will be
up true yeah yeah so I mean we're not
dealing with static income what's your
new mortgage going to be 2500 what's the
loan
amount uh the loan amount will be right
about 300,000 okay oh wow we might bring
it down a little bit more we have um a a
little more than 100,000 save to put
down on it um I have over 130,000 equity
in the house that we currently live in
now um
okay so you're chunking 230 into it
already you know the other thing you
look up I mean inside of 10 years you
may have it paid for but you're not
going to need it but for 10 years more
well you got the little one but the the
I mean yeah you've not the school's not
forever but it it's um that's what I I
kept thinking if you get 10 good years
out of this you've knocked most of the
issue out and between your income coming
up paying off the mortgage or getting
close you got all kinds of options if
the thing breaks down out there 8 N9 10
11 12 years from now and that would be
only dealing with the baby then yeah
we've seen the average it takes for
folks following the baby steps to pay
off their mortgage is seven years MH if
they do the 15 so you're going to be
right there man it would not surprise me
that you were not debt free in 7 to 10
years house and everything which again
changes the whole equation if the school
thing Turns Upside down on you that's
pretty cool pretty cool Misty is in Los
Angeles hi Misty welcome to the ramsy
show hi guys how are you good afternoon
afternoon how can we
help um I just started listening to you
guys a couple months ago um downloaded
your app getting ready to launch it I am
in quite a bit of debt I do have a
savings and I wanted to get your advice
on shall I dip into the savings pay off
my debt kind of like what you guys state
with your baby
steps um sure sounds fun how much debt
have you
got um I got about
$110,000 worth of debt and how much in
this
savings I have about
265,000 so what would be wrong with
writing a check tonight and being
debt-free
the only hesitation I have you'd only
have
$160,000
Misty I think I'm going to cry wipe your
tears with $100
bills
you know my thing is is that years ago I
paid off debt before and I just re R you
know got it going so I'm trying to fix
my core because that's a good that's a
good reason I like that
reason silly as it sounds I mean I'm
smart I
old I'm 46 years old I also own a house
but I don't consider that is it paid for
debt my house is not paid for and it's
kind of funny in a I have two two homes
so I have one home I own in Arizona that
I'm paying a mortgage on and my job is
in California so I do rent oh um okay
yeah so so it's more like a retirement
home I've been paying off but it's in a
pretty good shape it's how long would it
take you of being on a budget on the
every dollar budget app that George
shows you how to do it how long would it
take you to feel confident that Misty is
not going to ever go back into
debt how long would it take I mean how
many how many months of doing a budget
consecutively where you had power over
money instead of it having power over
you how long would it take for you to
build confidence in
Misty you know I don't think very long
you know you guys got yeah you got me
analyzing I started seeing where my
money was going um I started making some
serious changes just in this last month
after listening to you um like you said
every dollar you know um I think you're
I think I've been doing this 30 years I
think you're okay I love that you are
concerned about not changing your
behavior and going back into the hole
that is a very wise lady that says that
the fact that you said that out loud
probably means you're okay because
you're attacking this you're addressing
it the subject is now kind of uh it's
actually interesting to you for the
first time I'm going to make this
stinking money behave so it all get away
from me I don't like this feeling of
chaos and being out of control I want to
be intentional that's kind of risen up
in your throat hasn't
it it it has it has but you know my
question you know right now I take home
about
11,500 a month sometimes 12,000 but my
bills are 95 yeah but your debt free
because we just paid it all off that'll
free up some payments which is only
going to help your budget and like you
said a budget is just paying attention
to your money and so go sign up for our
free webinar we we have going on
everydollar.com budgeting there's one
coming up over an hour we're going to
walk you through how to use it you said
you downloaded it haven't launched it
yet we're going to give you three months
free premium too get you started on it
cuz I think a three months Misti is
going to really feel good about Misty
don't write the check the first month
right at the second month if you don't
write the second month for sure write it
the third month and be debt free I think
I think you got this kiddo uh hang on
we'll help you and get you signed up
that puts us hour the Ramsey Show in the
books we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
Prince of Peace Christ Jesus hey it's
George camel if you like what you heard
in this episode and want to know more
about getting started on the Ramsey Baby
Steps go to ramsy solutions.com and
click on the get started button we'll
help you figure out the best next step
for you based on your specific situation
that's Ramy solutions.com and click get
[Music]
started
e